i'd like to say this i can't remember
where i heard it but i heard it many
years ago that when we were young
television was free but we paid for our
music and now it's exactly opposite
we're happy to pay for television and
then complain about there
being nothing to watch but we want our
music free
as a champion of the power of music what
is it that you can communicate in a book
that you can't communicate in a song
well a book people can take their time
through it
where a song is meant to be heard not
note
by note where a book can be read
literally word
for word and it goes at the reader's
speed
a book is meant to for you to kind of
like hear my vision
in its entirety whether it's three
minutes or ten
all right so it's it's it's you kind of
taking on my journey
at my time my speed um but they both
have their their pluses and their
minuses
with the book you can go at your own
speed you can read a word and put it
down
come back read another word if you if
you want and but you'll still get the
same story
why were you compelled to write this one
because it reaches people in different
ways
yeah just to be able to take these
messages i could put these messages in a
song but a song
is is meant to give one message
like you know you have a you have what
they call now a hook
you have your chorus line and then you
kind of describe that line
but the book is a is allowed to take you
on a story
that that's like a movie it can take you
you know
the a book can can span years
within its pages where a song is usually
a message
and a story a small story might help
describe that message
but a a a song is meant to be
shorter a shorter message
more uh um
concrete more you know fixed on a
message where the book
is a journey is a bigger journey what's
the story of the spirit of music then
um it's my call to people
not just musicians to really connect
with music
again the uh and to raise
an awareness that we may be
losing that connection and we may be
losing
uh it's like if if the only thing we ate
was fast food
someone would need to remind us that
there's food from
the ground from a garden there might be
healthier food someone would need to
remind us of that
well i think we've kind of entered into
the age of fast music
and i'm trying to put out the the
reminder and even the warning signs
of where we could be headed what are we
talking about here i know that you break
down in the book
about the quality of music
and you do some comparisons but i mean
are you talking about the way that it's
distributed the reason that artists are
making music like
what are your issues here my issues are
the same as what we're facing right now
with the pandemic
chris imagine if we couldn't touch each
other anymore
shake hands see our family we had to
communicate from now on
like this we'd get used to it this isn't
really that bad is it
it's only that bad when we realize what
we've lost
i can't hug my wife and my kids if i
can't
shake your hand and give you a hug and
feel your energy
anymore and it has to be done like this
you know
we uh we're feeling the effect of this
pandemic and not being able to even
shake a hand
right but what if we didn't notice what
if the next generation came and then the
next generation came and they grew up
like this and this is all they knew and
they thought
this was normal us old-timers would be
saying no
no you need to touch it what is that
what do you mean i can't touch you you
know
so music is kind of the same way right
now our kids are growing up thinking
that an
mp3 which i described in the book
as a quarter of an inch right where we
started
with a foot all right and i just made up
these numbers
we started with the foot now we're down
at a quarter of an inch or less and this
is what our kids are growing up thinking
as
normal right so we're not
we're not receiving music in its
entirety
anymore right we listen to music
by ourselves we don't even listen to an
artist's whole
album right we pick the songs we want
listen to them out of order
and think we that that we've really
gotten the artist vision
so it'd be like taking my book reading
the chapters out of order but only
reading the ones you want
and think you read the book right it
doesn't really work that way
so that's what i'm seeing today
and we don't even want to pay for the
music we get
all right i'd like to say this i can't
remember where i heard it i wasn't
clever enough to come up with this but i
heard it many years ago that
when we were young television was free
but we paid for our music
and now it's exactly opposite we're
happy to pay for television and then
complain about there
being nothing to watch
but we want our music free
what's been lost what are we talking
about here for the people that aren't
audiophiles or musicians like you
just how much of a difference are we
talking about with how we listen to
music now
we're talking about a huge difference
and it's the same way again
i think fast eating fast food is
a great analogy because you can make
anything taste
good but it doesn't mean that the
nutrients are
there and it doesn't mean that it's
as healthy there is health there right
if i was
uh you know starving or or on a desert
island
and i found a you know a hamburger from
a fast food place i
i chomp it down quickly but
it doesn't mean it's as healthy as
coming from the ground
and when music comes from the ground per
se meaning from the healthy source
and has not been compressed or
diminished
so think about it chris the music that
we hear on our radio now
has the quality is already down we're
not talking about
vinyl which was analog and had more
frequencies
but and we're not talking about live it
starts with live music
the same way we're hearing each other's
voice it's compressed and digitized
it's not the same as if we were in the
same room where we would feel our breath
the energies would actually permeate our
skin
doesn't just touch the ears it touches
the whole body
and there's a whole thing called
cymatics now where they're actually
showing
how these vibrations affect us
you can go online now and type in
cymatics or type in
sound and sand and they'll play a a note
and you'll see the sand make these
shapes where there's
people that have put out books now where
they're showing how these vibrations
affect everything the way a tortoise
shell looks the fact that we each have
an individual fingerprint it's because
every vibration is different
none of them are identical right so it's
showing how these vibrations affect our
our lives but what if these vibrations
have been diluted
okay so now we take live music then we
take it and put it on vinyl it's less
than live music
then we make it digital and use a
waveform make a cd now it's getting
smaller
still sounds good right fast food tastes
good but it's not just about
the taste or the sound it's about what's
really there or not there
then we take that waveform and make it
into an mp3 which is only a tenth
the size of a waveform so that's why i
say if a waveform that's on a cd is six
inches
an mp3 is only 0.6 inches a half an inch
put that through computer speakers or
headphones it could be a quarter of an
inch
but that's only part of it so we
understand that the frequency
and i i could call it quality but i'll
stay away from that
the the amount of of in the amount of
information
is drastically uh diminished
but then we go further and we pitch
correct everything
these days instruments voices have been
pitch corrected
so we say that there's 12 pitches even
though there's more
the good singers will bend between those
pitches
and show you that there's more that's
why you feel that it's those
bends and things that permeate your your
soul and you feel that you take that
away
the music is perfect right
so we've diminished the pitches we've
also what we call quantized everything
quantizing is like pitch correction but
it's done to rhythm
where it makes every rhythm perfect so
now you're not getting the music that
sways with your heartbeat the way it did
and the beatles did
and the and and miles davis and uh you
know led zeppelin
and those groups did skinner you know
the music sped up slowed down we're not
getting that anymore everything that's
perfect so we're not getting all the
rhythms
we're not getting all the pitches we
already talked about the quality
the frequencies aren't there but then
we'll go and compress everything
so we've taken the dynamics out
compressing and limiting
compressing means that all the dynamics
that are here
are now here so all that soft stuff
you don't really hear soft music on the
radio it's all here
that's why when you're watching
television the commercials come in and
they're loud
because they're compressed to be at the
loudest possible spectrum
at least the tv show has a little bit of
softness
right but the spectrum is really a lot
bigger so we've compressed everything so
we're not getting all the dynamics
we're not getting all the pitches we're
not getting all the rhythms
we're not getting all the frequencies
the quality
right and then what used to be called
pop music when i was a kid
pop music just meant popular
so if miles davis was popular that was
played on the pop station
but it would be played right next to
leonard skinner if leonard skinner was
popular
and then the next thing would be the
jackson five the next song would be the
beatles
whatever was popular was on the pop
radio station
now pop music has been deleted i mean
i'm sorry not deleted dilute diluted
and i'm not here to say whether it's
better or worse even though you can
probably read between my lines
right but pop music is now basically a
four chord song
you've got to get to the chorus really
quickly
right it's not about the music it's
about getting to the hook and getting
you singing along with this
hook really fast
and then the hook is not really allowed
to say much
right every once in a while song that
has a real meaning
comes through and sneaks through and
makes the world better
but it's not really about that anymore
so
a lot has been diluted and then in the
book
in the first chapter i relate it and
compare it to
a person's body who gets sick
okay let's say somebody gets cancer god
forbid
your whole body doesn't have to have
cancer over your whole body for the
whole body to die
you just have to have the illness in
enough in one part of the
body enough that the whole body will die
so how much of music has to get sick
before all the music dies that's the
story
the fictional story of the spirit of
music and it started with
the music lesson book it started there
in the first book where you find that
music says she's sick
i'm dying people don't feel me anymore i
have a more
intimate relationship with computers
than i do with humans anymore is what
music says
so we leave you there this book starts
there
music is disappearing dying still
trying to speak to people but we're not
listening
what's your answer here what's your
answer to this we have
a desire for convenience now people want
to be able to listen to
these things when they go how do we fix
it
well i'm i'm totally i i i'm reluctant
to try to totally give an answer
for one is because i don't know the
answer
i do know some things it's like we say
wow all we have is fast food
how do i get real food we know what to
do there's not only one way but we know
it needs to come from the ground
right where do we get it actually to get
real food you got to pay more for it
you know they make it hard whoever they
is makes it hard i can buy a
a two liter bottle of coca-cola
and nothing against coca-cola but i can
buy a 2-liter
bottle of it cheaper than i can buy a
small bottle of water
is that not done on purpose
right so with music
one of the things we can do is recognize
the issue maybe go as far as recognizing
it as a
problem remembering what music
really is how we used to listen to it
how music listening to music was a
communal thing
we listened to a vinyl record in groups
now we listen to songs individually
the one things that we can do and i put
this into book
is to feel music again
and i portray music as female because of
the energy she
she provides it but to to invite
her in in other words us musicians
we play as if music is in my guitar
right there's no music in my guitar i've
got a guitar sitting right there you
don't hear a thing
it doesn't make sound until i touch it
no more than your mouth does the
talking you use an instrument when you
talk
but you don't say oh i speak mouth right
we don't name the instrument
the instrument is a tool that allows you
to express
right we've kind of lost that connection
of expression with music
because music is a part of that
expression it helps us
but we think music only comes from us we
forget that it's already there and that
we join with it
so we can feel music again feel it on
your skin
feel it from the inside the way a child
does if a song comes on a child doesn't
have to ask you how to do
how to dance how to move am i allowed to
sing
the child just reacts we've forgotten
how to do that
and in many cases the more i learn about
music
the less i feel the music i start
thinking my way through it
so bring it back to the feeling part
allow music to
to speak to you right
instead of us just saying that the
song's going to be this or that
let music speak to us and and reconnect
in a real way and to me it comes down to
feeling listening and allowing it to
enter us rather than just us putting it
out
that's a part of it from an artist's
perspective
what are they supposed to do if the
cardi b whap hook as quick as possible
auto tune quantized compressed down so
it's as loud as it can be
if these are the songs that are making
it to the top of the spotify charts or
hitting number one in the uk
surely it's going to be a very difficult
road for some sort of artist to say i'm
going to choose to not
not compete in terms of that level of
popularity i'm going to go for something
that's more subtle and nuanced
absolutely
absolutely but those songs will only be
number one if we support them
right a fast food restaurant can't exist
unless we support them
right a politician can't exist unless we
support
them so we can blame
we can blame labels and artists but it
starts from the consumer
we really do run the show if we don't
support it
if we demand that our artists uh
do more quality music they will do it
if we support the artists who aren't as
famous
but are making the music i also just say
real music
at the risk of being offensive if we
support them
right and don't get drawn in by
uh the hooks we even call them hooks now
in music
right real songs real music didn't need
a hook
the song was good the singer was good if
aretha franklin sang a note
if willy nelson sings a note i'm
listening
right because it's real right bob dylan
questionable whether he can even
sing he's real
and you feel that the realness of him
connects to the realness of me
and i have to stop whatever i'm doing to
listen
right you can tell that the music today
is good but
it's not as deep it doesn't affect you
the same it hits you
on a on a higher
on a more shallow level like the water
is not as deep
and the proof of the matter is you take
a beethoven or a bach or bronze their
music's been around for hundreds of
years
we're still listening to aretha franklin
but how long do these songs today last
right a month at most and then we're
moving on
so it's it's it's the depth is not there
it's not that the depth can't be there
right but even when the the quality the
the
artist is deep if we put it out only
on these limited uh
platforms it can't
reach us the same it can't nourish us
the same way
so if if we support
less less will rise to the top
and and i'm not trying to be disgraceful
to any artist cardi b
or anyone but you vote with your ears
with this stuff one of the things that i
think is interesting
you vote with your ears so what it is
that you listen to
is what you end up what we
we vote with our ears and our actions
our ears and our actions right what we
what we pay for
what we buy right it's a money-driven
system so you know if
yeah yeah you're right we vote with our
ears but it is more than that also
what i think is interesting is talking
about using the word hook
so one of the things i've been doing
this year is working hard on the youtube
channel which is a part of this
and there is a framework that all
youtubers use called the hive
framework and it's hook intro value uh
and then
a call to action at the end and that
hook within 15 seconds
you need to tell the listener or the
viewer what it is that they can expect
you need to deliver on the value
proposition of the thumbnail and the
title that they've clicked on and you
need to open the loop so that they stick
around to watch what happens next
so it would appear that it's not just in
music
but it's also in food it's a race to the
bottom of the brain stem
how can we get the sensations that we
know are going to trigger something
which causes us to act in a more
addictive way
so the an entire body of work which i
learned about last year called
orification which is the design of the
texture of food
so ancestrally it would have been very
rare for us
to have ever encountered foods that had
two textures in them
it would have been slimy berries it
would have been the
slippery texture of meat it would have
been the crunchy texture of some
some grains or something like that or
some nuts very rarely would you have had
something that was both crunchy and
fluffy together
and now think about the most addictive
foods that you can get the oreos of the
world the french fries of the world
this design this uh oratory design
of what is happening when you put it in
your mouth
is trying to trigger all of these
different things what is it that we're
doing
with regards to the hook in a youtube
video the zygarnic effect which is the
open loop closed loop system that the
bra
the brain doesn't like having unanswered
questions it's why this cliffhanger's at
the end of tv shows
so again with that here's a thing that
you need to know
oh well i better stick around i don't i
can't click off onto the next one
because i gotta i gotta do that thing
and it would appear that as our
understanding of how
human motivation works has improved it
has caused this race to the bottom
and inevitably when that happens you
sacrifice some of the nuance some of the
art
and some of the richness that you
mentioned earlier on
yeah um
in many cases and and this is how it
used to be in all cases
in music a hook was not needed
because the hook was the quality of the
artist
if aretha franklin breathed you went
whoa
right i mean you felt it because it was
real aretha franklin wasn't famous
because she was
uh a sex symbol because because she
barely wore clothes because she she
shook her body
she was famous because she was good
and she was good in a real way that was
the the criteria for being famous in the
past
you just had to be good that was it
think about that that was it it just had
to be good
what a concept nowadays you need a hook
we need something to pull you in because
i may not have anything behind this
but i gotta get you some kind of way but
when you have something that's
real word will spread
and you don't need a hook
right so if we have a hook make sure
there's something behind it
make sure there's some quality because
what ends up happening
is we get the hook and that's what
that's what a lot of music again i sound
very very negative and i don't mean to
because there's a lot of great things
out there you just have to find it
right it's out there but these days
it's the hook a lot of the times with
nothing
i shouldn't say nothing with very little
behind it
for example what we're teaching on a lot
of these performance shows
and you know like american idol and the
voice and things like that
very entertaining shows but what singers
are learning
is i have to get to my high note within
you know the first 20 30 seconds
right i have to dress a certain way
i have to be thin right i have to be
beautiful
i have to have these hooks and if i have
enough of these hooks my quality can be
less
that's what we've been teaching us
teaching people if i have enough of
these hooks i wear a little bit of
clothes i shake my butt
i'm beautiful i'm thin i don't have to
be able to sing
we see that over and over right
now when somebody comes through who can
sing
you feel the difference we feel the
difference
so the more real it is
right the more real it is the realness
of you
will be attracted to the realness of
whatever it is
right man and it's kind of related to
why we can see
a car accident on the side of the road
especially a bad one
and we have to slow down and and take it
in it's because
we feel it okay we didn't see the
accident we didn't
see the the hook or whatever we didn't
see the the main thing
but whatever is there is real it
connects to us someone is hurt
and we feel that right
so i think
i mean just just for us artists i want
to just make sure that that we have
real substance there
and it's substance that makes things
better and that
uh you know we we sub and then we start
supporting
what's real from the ground up
everything's got to be driven on on this
planet from the ground up we see that
our politicians want to fight each other
it's a it's a game to them right they
even call each other my opponents
you know it's a game but they're using
our money to play
the game they're using our lives to play
the game
and we have to speak up and you see it
starting to happen
excuse me you see it's starting to
happen more
but it uh in our business in the music
business
uh it it has to happen that way we have
to drive it
so if your show's gonna have a hook
great
you want people you know that's why i
want a beautiful
cover on my book you know on my album i
want you to see something that you're
going to like but
behind it needs to be something of
substance something that is real
talking about accidents you have a
section in the book where you talk about
coincidences and accidents can you
explain your view on that
sure coincidences are just things we
didn't expect to happen
it's like they kind of broke the rules
you know
i don't know how it happened this person
was just there
we just met you know if i knew i was
going to have a meeting with my hero
herbie hancock or something if i if we
set it up
and then we got together and we met
that wouldn't be a coincidence but if he
just showed up there
and we met same outcome
it would be a coincidence because we
don't know how or why it happened
so it's a coincidence but in in in
one sense of the war world word there
aren't
coincidences there's always something
behind the scenes
that we didn't we don't we didn't see
making it happen
so in a sense uh a coincidence is like a
magic trick
you have the result but you don't know
how you got that result there was just a
rabbit in the hat
i don't know how so it's like a trick we
call it a coincidence in life
um but there's always something behind
it there is a
whatever you want to call it behind it
that makes that coincidence happen
and uh when you
live no i'll put it this way however you
live
will determine
what the coincidences are
in your lives you know in other words
like people say you're lucky
you know you can earn your that luck you
can you can make yourself more lucky
by by living in a life that uh
that other people are going to benefit
from you being lucky you know the fact
that you have a show
people are going to benefit right the
more people that
can benefit from your show your your
show will start having coincidence
better coincidences
you know that's just the way the way it
works in life
and what about accidents accidents are
the same
but usually just coincidences are things
you wanted accidents are things you
didn't want
i think you say yeah is it coincidences
or when life whispers and accidents are
when life shouts
yeah yeah accidents are when when when
for me when we're not listening
to what life is telling us and life can
be whatever you want it to be
insert your word when we're not
listening it winds up being an accident
okay and that's life shouting at you
saying listen listen
you have an accident you you know you
you you burn yourself or whatever but i
will say this in my own life just about
every case
where i have an accident it could be
small
i've i leave the house and i forgot my
whatever i needed
right that's an accident i didn't mean
to leave i left it by accident so
actually
doesn't mean i'm about to die accidents
can be very small
but in many cases especially the small
ones i left my keys
and i locked myself out i can rewind the
tape in my
brain and find the place or places
where i neglected to listen
right i can go back and say wow
right there life was telling me i can
remember looking at my keys earlier that
day
they're on the desk i should have picked
them up and put them in my
bag right then it's funny that i can do
that i can rewind it
and see where life was telling me
right so if i get on an airplane and i'm
sitting next to herbie hancock
whoa what a coincidence right if i'm
get on the airplane and i'm sitting next
to a bomber
who's about to hijack the plane that's
an accident
[Laughter]
right same thing we just usually like
the coincidences
i think accidents certainly seem to
happen
when you're not paying enough attention
if you're focused on the things that are
happening you can mitigate
most of the accidents that occur so
coincidences are the same
yeah that's a good paying attention they
just they just happened you weren't
paying attention you don't know how they
happen they're the same
i'm sorry but i interrupted you i
apologize no uh
as a good example i ruptured my achilles
last year playing cricket
which is like the most british way that
anyone's ever ruptured in achilles and
it was the first time i'd played that
sport in 10 years but what was the
signal of that i wasn't paying enough
attention to
my work capacity versus the load and the
demands i was putting on my system
well potentially what's that saved me
from maybe
i would have decided that after two
sessions of learning to rock climb i was
going to go free rock climb somewhere or
i was going to jump out of an airplane i
was going to do this that and the other
and yes sometimes i think there's a lot
more that we can take because
the only reason an accident's occurred
is because there's been
some prelude to it something has
occurred in advance of that
that has led up to it happening you know
being hit by a car because you weren't
looking at the street okay well
why weren't you looking at the street
maybe you're not looking at other stuff
as well
maybe there's other things in your life
that you're not looking at what can this
one accident and this is why
people find symbolism in these big
accidents or these big incidents that
occur within their life
because they're usually an aggregate for
a lot of other little things that have
happened
it just happens to be this one which is
large and symbolic and memorable
i agree with you thousand percent so in
other words
uh you are finding the way i see it
you're finding the blessing
in the accident the meaning
that can help you avoid the bigger
accident that could be up ahead
and i agree the pandemic that we're in
right now
is a big accident but there's silver
linings everywhere
you know if we if we dare to find them
there are silver
linings and hopefully this big you know
year
or year and a half or two year long
accident can help our kids
from having to go through another one
you know so hopefully we can learn from
the accidents
and there's always learning to be done
thinking about it in that way the
pandemic that we've been delivered
although it's been
unfortunate and a catastrophe as
pandemics go
it's not that vicious it's not
sufficiently lethal
but what did it teach us it taught us
that we have
no idea how to shut down international
travel when there's a pandemic
we have no idea how many people need
ventilators
we still had to take although it was a
world record it still took nearly a year
to develop a vaccine then multiple
vaccines then distributing the vaccine
then
what the long-term effects if and when
another pandemic comes around which it's
going to happen it happens about every
100 years or so
we're going to be better prepared modern
society understanding how to generate
ppe how to create a vaccine how to shut
down travel
and um yeah maybe that's the same way
that the accidents happen
with personal people's lives as well
if we learn from it yeah right
the signs are there right life is not
trying to hurt us life is trying to help
us
so the accident is always a way to get
better but it's up to us
if we don't listen we'll just keep
having accidents
right but if we learn the next accident
guaranteed will be
different to take us
further you know so if we learn from
this pandemic we won't have this
again but we'll have something different
because it's about growth and you don't
have growth
without problems right you don't learn
to walk and run without falling
your body heals stronger once it gets
injured once it gets
you know you get a cut the skin grows
back
stronger if i walk on my feet long
enough the skin grows in thicker
you know that's that's how life works it
takes life works off of opposites
it takes this to produce that so
accidents are necessary
things need to go wrong if everything
went right we'd be bored
life would be just boring right and i
like to say this a lot nobody talks
about the time we drove
through the desert you know 100 miles
and the car worked nothing broke down
the air condition was good
right i had plenty of i didn't even run
out of gas
you know and i got there on time right
nobody talks about that
right we talk about when how it went
wrong
right even if we have the next 50 years
are the best
ever after 2020 let's say
it just gets live for the next 50 years
it's like uncle
and just like unbelievably good guess
what year we're going to talk about
not the good ones the bad one
right so that's a part of living on
earth i don't know what it's like
off of earth but on earth we have what i
call yin yang
we have opposites because you can't have
the good
without the bad you need that balance
on earth and that's what it's about so
it's all bad things are always going to
happen
talking about challenges do you still
get nervous before you perform
it depends on the performance i i could
easily say
no easy say no but it's because i'm
normally doing things that i'm
comfortable with
if i go play a concert in london in
front of a bunch of bass players
or i go play my normal gig i know what
you like
you know that's easy i can do that in my
sleep
but i got called one time to play
upright bass for chick korea for a week
during his 75th birthday
concert where he did eight weeks at the
blue notes
and i had to come in and sub because his
real bass player couldn't get there
now i don't play upright bass i own
one it's over there but now here i am
within a week less than a week i gotta
learn this music
and he ended up sending me the wrong
music that i rehearsed for two days by
myself
and then i get the wrong and then i have
to get the right music on upright in
front in the blue note
you know video tape publicized
70 tickets turning 75 a bunch of
different bands
and here i am you know with chick and
and and hubert laws and
ravi coltrane and lenny white and me on
upright you talk about nervous
oh my goodness yes
so but it was good for me i learned a
lot
so i can't say i don't get nervous i can
say i usually don't
usually oh my goodness for one i learned
i need to practice on the upright bass
so i literally literally traveled with
the upright bass for the next two years
and i played it every night i did it for
two years i toured a record my last
record called tripnatics
which is a trio with dennis chambers on
drums bob francischini on saxophone
and me on bass so i played that bass
every night for two years because i said
i'm going to
be better if i ever get this call again
but the real lessons came from chick
korea
i learned that you can loan someone
confidence
you can believe in someone more than
they believe
in themselves and you can cause them
to rise to the challenge it was because
of chick korea's belief in me
i didn't believe in myself i i literally
when i got the call i
had my manager i said call chick korea
back
because upright is not what i do i'm
thinking he probably went in his rolodex
looked up victor
and called the wrong victor you know
and i wanted to give him an out and say
hey look this is
you know make sure you know you called
me that's not what i do
he's he won't but he apparently wanted
me
so i had to think okay if he believes in
me this much
i need to believe in myself right and
then now
listening to a few of the recordings a
few of my friends sent me
some videos and in one case i can hear
myself
playing upright bass taking a solo and
he makes me solo
you know and i look at him like i'm done
and he's like nope and he nods
which means keep going and i'm listening
to this video now where i'm out of my
head
in the solo i'm i'm struggling i'm in my
head
i don't have the technique i'm thinking
too much
but now watching the video i hear chick
corea
feeding me ideas helping me
but i'm too closed off to hear him
would have been much better if i had
just opened up and do the things that i
teach
do the things that i tell people get out
of your head when you're soloing treat
it like a conversation listen to the
people you're talking
with not to if i had just
listened to chick we would have had the
dialogue he was trying to have
even though it's my solo it's still a
dialogue
but i treat it as know it i'm talking
and i'm in my head and i played
worse it was okay would have been much
better
if i had listened to what he was saying
i learned a lot how can people get out
of their own heads
with regards to that there's a lot of
people that will do things i have the
with the podcast
when i drop into flow when it's just me
and the person i'm speaking to
and i don't think about what i'm
thinking about i'm just hearing what
they say or
the athletes the teacher
whoever it might be getting out of our
own way and out of our own heads
is a difficult challenge yeah it's very
it's very very difficult um
there's things that we can do on both
sides of the issue there's things that
we can do for
people and then there's things that we
can do for ourselves and
and by no means do i have all the
answers but i have some
one of the things you can do is watch
yourself the way i watch to myself with
chick
where i'm out of my head now and i'm
able to watch it
now i can think more realistically
where i'm not attached to it emotionally
our emotions speak so loudly
and in many cases we think the audience
is
thinking something that they're not
thinking right we
think the audience is like noticing
every mistake
and thinking oh you suck oh i heard that
oh your
audience isn't thinking that if the
audience is there
they're your cheerleaders they want you
to succeed that's why they're there
they're open to whatever you do mistakes
and all
it's literally like the cheerleaders for
a football team
right you're cricket team if you have
cheerleaders you could be
losing by a bunch but the cheerleaders
aren't going to say you suck
chris your team is horrible you they're
still going to cheer you on
right that's what the audience is doing
but we think they're not
so we're not we're not thinking
realistically
so one is we can realize that and and we
can do it by
getting out of it and watching it
without the attachment of emotion
so we can see what really happened and
then 99 out of 100 times you'll go well
it wasn't as bad as i thought right
because in
the midst of it we're not usually
thinking realistically
right we're thinking about what might
happen and what they might think about
it
and we're thinking ahead about things
that haven't happened but what is
happening is where we need to be
enjoying the moment so that's one start
the other thing is to prepare
just really prepare and we have to
remember that preparing doesn't just
mean play the notes right
right because playing the notes right in
my room is different than playing the
notes right in front of
a hundred or thousand people
so play a bunch of gigs
and make mistakes right even if you're
at home and you're working on the gig
and all you have is your dog to play for
play for your dog
because doing it for someone changes
the mentality right the
other thing is to help other people
help other people feel good and to get
out of their heads
compliment criticizing a kind way to
help people
because what you're doing when you're
giving knowledge
you're you're realizing that i can't
give you what i don't have
all right you can't give anything you
don't have if you if i want to
you know borrow ten dollars from you
you have to have ten dollars first so if
you're gonna give it to me you have to
have it
so when you give even criticism negative
criticism that means you have negativity
in you you can't give what you don't
have so the more you
give the more you build up inside
yourself so if you can
give people confidence the way chick was
giving me
it actually helps you so those are our
few things
really prepare prepare for the gig but
you got to prepare
mentally also not just physically
mentally i didn't throw this in there
but always listen to the people you're
playing with
the same way you're listening to me
because i talk too much
but when you're doing an interview like
there are some interviewers who aren't
listening
to the people they're talking to the
interviewer just wants to talk
and during the interview you end up
learning more about the interviewer
than the interviewee i've had a lot of
those interviewers
interviews like that so really listen
when you're playing you're not
in in it by yourself even when you're
playing solo you're not alone
you have music's help you also have an
audience's help
listen to all of them right the
the the first thing i said was the first
thing i was saying is uh
forget what the first thing i said was
oh yeah
uh get out of your head by watching
yourself listen back to it later
but don't wait until the gig's over to
listen back to it listen to yourself
practicing record it
then put your mind in the space that
okay now i'm on stage i'm in my bedroom
but i'm actually on stage record it
again
video it listen to it right maybe i'm
looking like this
the whole time that's not fun for an
audience
all right so videotaping and really get
out of your head and watch it
and then don't put uh don't put words in
the audience's mind
unless they're good words because your
audience is your cheerleaders they're
there for you that's the only reason
they would pay hard-earned money
is to come cheer you on not to come
criticize you if they don't like you
they're not there i love the insight
about projecting
your fears and internal phobias onto the
people that are watching
that um it strikes a chord with so much
stuff i've been thinking about recently
i had a tedx talk which is just about to
come out i know that you've done
one or maybe more um and
during the preparation for that uh
usually for me public speaking it's not
something that
i'm familiar with i haven't done it
before properly
and although i talk for hours and hours
every week on this show it's very
different
right monologuing to a room of people
with big audio visual team and
i've got this script and it's for ted oh
my god like i need to know
what i'm talking about it's supposed to
be i'm with these titans of
intellectual curiosity and performers
and athletes and musicians
and um all of that went away when i'd
prepared
there was nothing left there was no
place for fear to hide because i knew
that script front to back inside out
stanza by stanza line by line i knew the
inflection points i knew the
i knew the typos in the script where i'd
accidentally put the wrong piece of
punctuation in and scribbled it out with
a little pen
and i knew it to such a degree with so
much fidelity
that my worst possible performance was
still far better than anything that i
needed to give
and sure enough i went out we had an
hour block
within which because it was virtual um
recorded by an
in-person group but there was no
audience and then it's going to go up on
the on the youtube channel and so on and
i went out
and they said right you've got one hour
and we can do as many takes as you want
so if you want to do it and then go
again so i walked out
and delivered the talk one and done
straight through
i was like okay well what i'll do i'll
go and grab a quick glass of water and
then
let's go again and the video guy who's
my buddy james
stuck his head out from beside the
camera and was like why do you want to
do that
i was like well i'll do i'll do it again
you know like
maybe i'll get it a bit better and he's
like dude you're not going to do it
better than that
he's like you're not going to do it
better than that and that was it i'd
prepared for three months to do this 15
minute thing
and he was like right you're done you
can go home now and um
yeah preparation it's such a
such an obvious answer to a lack of
confidence or self-esteem
yeah if you're concerned about something
preparing until
you're so much more competent than
you're ever going to need to be
and this is why you know what's
something that's interesting you know
when you see these fighters boxers and
mma fighters
in the press conference before they go
up often when i look at
them i think how could you have
this much self belief like they must all
of them must be playing a role
but then when you realize that those
guys are training
four hours to six hours a day in a fight
camp with people who are around them
that are telling them
what they're gonna do they've got
strategists their nutrition styled in
their sleep styled in their recovery
styled in
and you actually realize well no no hang
on a second this guy
is putting everything he's got this
genetic freak who was built for this
sport whose passion is this sport
is now dedicating every waking moment to
being the best that he can be
why wouldn't he think that he's a killer
why wouldn't he think that he's going to
destroy anybody that they put in front
of him i'm the best on the planet
that's and it was the first time that i
was able to
catch a glimpse of what that level of
preparation gives you
nice nice yeah the mind is controlling
it you know
the mind is powerful a powerful thing
but it starts for us very very young
usually when we start going to
uh school
that that confidence that we had in
ourselves because we did
we had that confidence as a kid
you know two three four five years old
oh yeah
but we quickly get robbed of that
because uh most public institutions that
we belong to
belong to do not foster that thought
process
right most of the times when we're
learning something new
when you learn anything new you're
probably going to make more mistakes
than you do getting it right
but in every case you hear about every
mistake
right so think about music lessons if
you're told you're wrong over and over
you're going to start playing just to
not be wrong anymore
but why we started playing was because i
enjoy it
i feel something when i do this right
for a child it's not about doing it
right it's about feeling right
you don't play air guitar to get every
note right
right it's all about a feeling but now
it's about doing it right
and you're going to do it wrong in the
beginning more than you do it right
so our focus changes and in most cases
i think this is true in most cases
there's nothing that returns into our
life
to bring us back so most people will go
through our careers whatever it is
especially our musical careers
not believing in ourselves the way we
did before we learned anything
but like i said with chick corea he was
giving that confidence
back to me even in the midst of my
struggle on stage
i look back and say wow he was still
believing in me you know and so
we need to do that to people to the
people you interview
to the people your students your your
siblings your your spot your
spouse it's what the world needs we just
need a a confidence booster
right we're told to be fearful
uh to fit in don't stand out
uh you know where the proof of the
matter is that you have the only
fingerprint that's ever going to be here
in the history of humans
right past present future you've got the
only one of these
right that shows how special you really
are
but it's hard to find anything that
helps us live out that speciality
specialty to help us know how special we
are
and i was lucky enough to have parents
that drilled
that into our heads as kids and i mean
drilled it
right but you got to remember my parents
were born in the 30s
i was born in the 60s it was different
for people of color back then
right we were facing a society that
would not support us
and my parents knew that
so they made sure we knew who we were
even if you didn't right so us
brothers we have tremendous confidence
in ourselves
borderline egotistical
right but really what it is if you look
up the word
ego it just means knowing who you are
having a sense of yourself knowing
yourself that's what it means
so you ask any of your friends that play
music hey are you a good pianist oh i'm
okay
i'm all right i try are you a good
guitarist
yeah i'm okay right go to the doctor and
ask the doctor if he's a good doctor
she's a good doctor are you a good
doctor and she said well
you know i'm okay i try right you'd be
out of there
we're supposed to have confidence in
ourselves
or else we're asking the audience to do
something i'm not even willing to do
please believe in me i believe in myself
whether you do or not
i know i'm not a good bass player i'm a
great bass player
but so are you so is the baby who's
never played bass
right because if somebody wants you
chris to play bass on a record
i'm not good enough to be chris no
matter how good you think i am i'm not
good enough to be you you're the best at
being you
right why doesn't society cause you to
see that and allow you to live that out
right it's again it's the fast food
method right we make fast food cheaper
and easier to get
than the healthy stuff
and teachers really you know when we're
not allowed to do that to each
individual student we have to treat you
as a whole
and make you all pass the test together
what do you do then to open up your
students creativity
and to allow them to gain some
confidence
right you focus on the students gifts
where most teachers i'll say a lot of
teachers focus on
the students uh faults
focus on their gifts and their faults
will disappear
right you teach a person how to do
something better by teaching them what
they
showing them what they already do well
for example my brother reggie best
teacher in the world
at least my world he's the one that
taught me he's my brother so when i'm
two and he's teaching me to play bass
he's only eight years older than me he's
only ten
right but by the time i'm five we're
gigging
right we're opening for curtis mayfield
on a superfly tour we're doing all this
crazy stuff
he also taught joseph who's three years
older than me so i'm two
reggie's teaching me bass joseph's five
reggie's teaching joseph the keyboard
in a few short years this ten year old
boy has us on tour good enough to be on
tour
right that's the kind of teacher he is
so
the real story is how did he learn it
because my parents didn't play music
but reggie has a new student or any
student
and let's say reggie's teaching the
student a c major
scale and the student plays a c
sharp most teachers will say
that's wrong don't play that right
reggie says
wait a minute that's the cool note
that's the note miles davis would use
man you're already in the back of the
book we're not in the back of the book
yet remember that note but let's come
back to it later
that's the cool note we're coming back
to that but right now
let's do it this way so he turns
the the wrong thing into the best thing
but here's the kicker here's the thing
he's not lying
that is the coolest note in a c major
scale at least in jazz
a c sharp is what's going to make people
go
that's what miles would do so it's not
like he's just
lying he's right that is a cool note but
let's come back to it later
so he compliments you he makes you feel
good about your
mistake you're already
miles davis
right and then even if you can only play
one note
he'll have you play that one note to
rhythm he'll put on a drum machine and
reggie gets the guitar out while you're
playing one bass note
and then he regis singing and all of a
sudden you're playing music
and then your parent comes to pick you
up from the lesson and your parents
about to open the door but they
listen wait a minute i hear a band in
there
then they open the door and it's your
their kid making music
the first day it's like big smile the
kid
feeling good you know that's why that's
how reggie teaches
he teaches you based on your gifts first
and in many cases you'll find out
what your other gifts are let's say you
love skateboarding
reggie will go on and learn about
skateboarding
so now he can relate this music to
things that you're already good at
things you already love rather than
starting you from the beginning as if
you don't know anything
the other thing i learned from my
brothers too is that let's say you have
a 10 year old student
music student most teachers will teach
that student as you know as if he knows
or she knows nothing
you're a beginner i'm going to fill you
with knowledge my brothers realize that
if you're 10 you've been listening to
music
probably 11 years already
right probably listening to music
already 11. so
anybody that's been doing something 10
or 11 years is not a beginner
this kid might just be a beginner to
learning to express their musicality
through an instrument
but our job is not really to teach them
to be good at the instrument
is to be good at expressing music the
instrument is just our tool
like teaching a baby to talk you don't
teach them how to work their mouth
you give them something to say you find
out what it is they want to say
they'll learn how to say it quickly so
reggie teaches us
that way what kind of music do you like
what songs do you like what do you want
to play
okay let's play that today
didn't i hear that you do an exercise
you have an exercise with your students
where you make them play the worst
possible style that they can don't you
when there's
to to fill them with confidence you
don't tell them to try and play as well
as they can you say right let's all jam
together
and play the worst possible bass that we
can do
sure and it works every time the thing
is what we think is right
can be fit into a box i have to do this
and we think too much
right let's play jazz jazz to most
people is this i gotta play these notes
these notes
and and and when they do it and they're
thinking so hard emotionally
there's nothing there there or i should
say very little there
but all of a sudden i say okay great you
played great if i was your teacher
i'd give you an a i said but now let's
try this let's just see who can let's
have a competition let's see who can
play the worst
right in the same way you started
smiling just at the thought
right because now it's open and it's fun
again
all of a sudden music is fun again we're
going back to the source the beginning
we get to be horrible that's always fun
right see it brings a big smile to your
face so all of a sudden
we're starting from emotion
not i have to be right and i got to be
serious and if i mess up i'm going to be
no we're letting you mess up this is
this this is what the whole thing's
about how
how worse can we be and what happens is
the musicians can't play badly
and what ends up happening is because
they stop trying
to be right the real person comes out
and the
uh the the emotion can't even be
measured
and what's good about that musician
finds its way to the forefront
and everybody listening goes whoa
now they may think they're bad but it
gets so good
and when i do this in front of an
audience with the musicians i always ask
the audience
which solo did you feel more
the good one they played or the bad one
which one did you feel more we're not
going to judge it
this was good which one reached you and
you felt
more and every time 100 the
the bad solo
and then i point out people won't
remember what you played when they walk
out of here
they're not going to remember your solo
they're going to remember what it felt
like
so if you can attach the feeling of the
bad one
the heightened intensity the dynamics
the not having to know what was going to
come out the
energy if you can combine that with what
you do know
you're automatically one of the greats
automatically and it happens like that
if you'll do it
there's an interesting thing that
happens during meditation um
toward the end of a session andy
puddycam the guy behind headspace
he instructs people to just let the mind
do what it wants
so you've been working on a particular
focus visualizing something
focusing on the breath whatever it might
be and then for the final minute of the
session he often says
and now just let the mind do whatever it
wants
every single time during a session for
years and years when i used to use
headspace
that period was where i found the most
peace
when i was able to let go of the
constrictions and the constraints and
the rules
that were saying okay you can't let the
mind wander and you've got to think
about the breath and you need to
visualize the
yellow light inside of your chest
whatever it might be
but when i was allowed to do it i
actually noticed that
that was when my mind was most free and
the same thing goes for this podcast i
had
robert green on six times new york times
best-selling author
intellectual titan historian fella
and he was one of the first big guests i
had and i over prepared
to hell i absolutely over prepared to
hell i had all of these questions in
front of me
remembering i've got one of the world
experts in human behavior and i'd just
written out a bunch of questions and i
wanted to ask him about all of this
stuff
and i look back and it was fine everyone
thought the same as your show
no one mentioned it in fact people
thought it was a good episode
but i looked back and i was like oh man
like i was in my own way i was in my own
head
i'd allowed the nerves to constrict me
into going through some rules
and then the best conversations that
happen are the ones where you
allow the mind to do whatever it wants
well a lot of the times we have to take
it away from you
so that when it's given back to you you
treat it
properly like the pandemic again we
can't
six feet of each other you can't shake
your hands
so now when we come back a mundane
handshake is going to mean something
right so normally we go through life
with the freedom
to let the mind do what it wants to do
but a lot of times the mind uh in what
we call
freedom uh we're really don't realize
we're restricting it
we're forcing the mind to think poor
things oh i'm gonna screw up
oh man i probably messed this up or you
know
you know we think poorly of ourselves
but because of this
medic excuse me meditation practice
where it shows you how to restrict the
mind and focus
focus all of a sudden it comes back to a
better place
it's sort of like taking a vacation from
home i'm sick of home
my goodness i got to be here but all i
have to do is go to a vacation for a day
ah my own bed right
so so that that's what it's like we got
to take it away so sometimes meditation
is that way it's not like you're
supposed to go through life that way
but without telling you it's fixing the
normal part of life
one question that i had that i thought
was quite interesting is how do you stay
healthy when you're on the road
before we got started we were talking
about how long you've spent away
touring playing shows what do you do to
ensure that you're not
falling to pieces yeah i'm
you do the same thing you would do at
home you know if you go to the gym go to
a gym
you know there's gyms all around the
world i'm not a gym person
because usually if i'm in a city it's
because i'm playing there
and i don't want to get recognized in
the gym
you know sweating and and you know
people seeing how much
weights i can't lift or whatever you
know i'm more private when it comes to
that
so so
my my main thing is you know mentally
being healthy
physically uh being as healthy as i can
eating well
but most of the exercising that i do is
done in my
hotel room which is a lot of
calisthenics
push-ups sit-ups different types of
things
you mentioned martial arts i used to do
martial arts as a kid so
there are a few of those things that i
still keep up but then i like to
i love to walk i'm not much of a runner
even though i'll do it some but i love
to walk and like a boxer a lot of most
of the time i'll travel with a jump rope
and so sometimes at night after a gig
when it's dark and no one can see me
i'll go in the parking lot and jump
through
that's cool do you find when you don't
do those things
how much of a noticeable impact is there
on your performance
when you're not looking after mind and
body
um um
it's a good question because i i haven't
let my body get too
far out of shape you know i've i've seen
photos where i'm heavier my stomach's
out but
i could still do a backhand spring or i
could still
you know play basketball or something so
i'm not too far gone
so a lot of what happens to me on stage
is
mental once my mind is right my body
will respond
hopefully and um but that's the struggle
i'm having right now i was just
mentioning you a minute ago this thing
called focal dystonia where my hands
so there's something going on with my
brain that's sending the wrong signal
to my hand so i'm dealing with that
right now and having to reprogram
but um i don't know i've just always
tried to keep myself
in some kind of physical good physical
condition
because we do play with our whole bodies
not just with our fingers and not you
know
it's not just a mental knowing the notes
but you know i've seen physically out of
shape people
make some good music
i don't know that being i don't know how
physical shape you know i don't know if
it really matters
to playing great music because i've seen
all of the above
but i do want to make sure that for my
own health that my body is in a
good condition yeah it's a bit of a
trope right to think about the band
that's going on tour that's
eating fast food and drinking every
night and
i wonder i often think how much of that
is to the detriment of the reason that
they're doing the tour
and um
well it's it's it's easy now these days
chris to find
good food wherever you are you know
i mean you know we have a lot of truck
stops here in the u.s and even if the
truck stops you can get healthy
vitamins and food and and you know
nuts and fruit at the you know though
you go to pay for your food or your gas
and there's fresh bananas right there
you know at the counter
so it's easier to stay healthy
these days but there have been a lot of
people i remember when michael hedges
was alive and
did some touring with him and uh he was
playing with michael mannering
and the flecktones and michael hedges
great guitarist did some touring
together
and it was the same with chick korea for
a while when we toured together
those people would always have certain
types of food
and ways of either preparing it and
cooking it
in their dressing room and in their
hotel rooms they were that particular
with their food i'm not that particular
with it
even though i will bring some things and
some snacks that i want to make sure
that i
eat and drink but i'm happy to go to
you know a good restaurant or a good
store and buy some things because it's
all available these days
what are some of your favorite venues to
play worldwide
um one of one of my favorites just
because it's so beautiful
is the outdoor place called tell you
ride in colorado in the united
states telluride colorado just because
it's way high up in the mountains and
you're on stage looking at waterfalls
and
snow-covered peaks and then down here is
a sea of people
and they're excited because it's a fun
festival that happens every year
so that's always fun but um
there are you know there are some
smaller video places
ronnie scott's is a great legendary
place
in uh in london so
that's always fun to get to play the
places that you know that your heroes
played
like the blue note in new york uh some
of those places aren't in new york
aren't there anymore but some of the
legendary places that you know
that i know my heroes stood in the same
place
and that's a lot of fun but there are
some places and you know
they're not all coming to mind right now
but some of them
some of the places are are just fun
because they're in a good area
or maybe the stage sounds great
or you know you have a good memory of
meeting someone there
you know i remember playing a place uh
and at the moment
i'm losing the the name of the place but
it was in san francisco
it's a nice theater and i can remember
being on stage and literally seeing
marcus miller walk through the front
door
with his base you know and that
memory brings back such a good feeling
of that night and that
venue um because he came and sat
in and jammed with us that night you
know so different venues can have bring
about you know good memories
that's awesome man well vic thank you
thank you for coming on the uh the
journey of learning about how you view
music the
spiritual side of it i think is is
really really interesting
and um i hope that we've opened some
people's eyes to
the sort of direction that we could go
in that where should people go they want
to check out some more stuff to do with
you or keep up to date
where's best sure well my website
victorwooten.com is the best place to
start
because everything else is can be found
from there
you can find my facebook page i'm on
facebook i'm on instagram
i'm on twitter um i try to answer my
messages it may take a while
but i try to answer my message but i'm
very reachable
um you know on all these platforms
i have a online store where you can find
most of my products my books my records
t-shirts hats all kinds of fun stuff
like that
and i usually my schedules there if i'm
touring if i'm doing workshops
there my music camps that i've been
doing for 21 years
uh this will make the 22nd year all of
that stuff can be found there
so um that's a good place if you want to
find out more
about me perfect thank you so
and much uh you you mentioned the
spiritual side sometimes
the word spirit or spiritual can can can
can like make it people
flip out a little bit but just do me a
favor and like and
if you could say give me three words for
you that describe
music music is fill in the blame what is
music to you just
anything that comes to mind don't even
think too movement rhythm movement
joy movement rhythm and joy okay so
think about that
um this is a question i ask students all
the time at workshops clinics
i think it may even been put into one of
the books the music lesson or the spirit
of music but whenever i ask these people
like you these questions i get these
beautiful words
right rhythm uh movement joy
right these are beautiful words but for
some reason
we pick up a bass or a piano or what and
we forget about those words
now it's like music is notes techniques
skills theory right we know without the
instrument in our hands
that those things i just mentioned are
not music music is really joy
it's movement so why don't we teach that
right why don't i ask you what is music
to you on the first day of classes
lessons and then i make sure that you
get better at that but no
i teach you notes skills
techniques and you have to get them
right to pass my class
and all of a sudden those beautiful
words are all but forgotten
so i always ask people what those words
are without an instrument in their hands
because then they go back to the source
and that source is spiritual
everything you said can be called
spiritual
so it doesn't have to become some
philosophy some it's just what it is
but we need to remember what it really
is
because when we play that's what we
should be playing
we shouldn't be playing techniques
scales
uh offender uh foldera
these are tools these are destinations
this is these are the tools we use to
express
those words but if those words are not
even in our minds
we are doing ourselves and our listeners
a disservice
so when i'm thinking spiritual i'm
thinking that
i'm not thinking some clouds in the sky
i'm thinking both feet planted firmly on
the ground
but knowing what i'm doing
and it's easy to get there i love it man
thank you thank you thank you so much
for your time today i really appreciate
it
i appreciate you too thank you
you